let's talk about what's going on with uh
with whitmer yes
because let's get into this this big
thing you're working on so we have the
story we got this one from click on
detroit michigan governor whitmer blasts
criticism over visiting sick father in
florida state leader reacts to criticism
and interview with the washington post
or she runs to the washington post
right they're very favorable towards
democrats click on
detroit you didn't cover it sorry guys
you hearing me
you didn't cover it and then click on
his writing
the governor of michigan went to the
washington post
yeah so what's up with this story
apparently she was criticizing people
who traveled criticizing florida
then she goes to florida no we gotta we
we are like
ground zero for the united states and
like raging
pandemic uh cases covent cases
now you know uh right around easter good
friday
everybody i'm not gonna lock it down
again
and it's now the date is coming i i'm
not a
pen uh a cova denialist in any way
you know try to be a good boy try to
respect my scottish mask
i caught it i'm over it that's why i'm
not wearing it you know i'm not a freak
but she says uh
listen don't travel to florida because
it's really bad there and they got
this uk variant uh we and they and i
think
maybe we got it from them
number one her chief operating officer
who's in charge
of distributing the vaccine
beats it down to margaritaville she's in
the siesta key or
something like that and meanwhile
whitmer's on the day is telling biden
give us the vaccine
unaware that the coo didn't order the
360
000 vaccines that were waiting for us
because she's down to margaritaville
wow with the teeny boppers while her
18 year old son is back home a covet
so you're traveling around with teeny
boppers you've been exposed to covid
and you're the chief operating officer
of the state so i get on to the next one
spring break the department of health
and human
services the chief medical director for
michigan
beats it down to margaritaville they
want to play funny with me
i know it you know i know it this you're
gonna confirm it or deny it because you
know i already know it
but where's margaritaville like what are
you referencing that would that be like
the gulf
like we're from michigan so these people
are traveling down to the gulf or
whatever they're
they're partying they're leaving
pandemic central
after they locked us down governor told
us all to stay put
try not to go down there do the right
thing
and our two top health advisors are down
there and we catch him
part three did you go governor
did you go she did didn't she because i
know you went
she did because i'm a reporter
i know people all over the place there's
nothing going to happen we don't know
about
but click on is not going to do it
npr's not going to do it i'll leave it
to you to
ask why they won't do it this is
germaine
so the governor now says well i didn't
go on spring break i went to see my
ailing father
snowbird mansion west palm beach
[Laughter]
my brother died my brother died three
weeks ago that's not funny
i couldn't be at his death bed people
couldn't go to funerals
people couldn't see loved ones in the
nursing homes
and you're making some cockamamie excuse
like this
this is not leadership
it's not everything's turned upside down
brother
our children's lives they're manic
they're sad they're confused right
they're staring at screens
we did what we were asked we did not
we thought we all row in the boat
together
when you know the top three officials in
michigan did this
that boat has sailed and when i flew
into charlotte
north carolina this morning whew that
was packed i felt like gulliver's travel
or uh rip van winkle
like i haven't seen a crowd like this in
a year and a half
and i'm i'm personally disgusted
and you can parse you can fake it
here's what will not be written about
the coveted response
it happened in an election year history
will not remember
this is the most important election of
our lifetimes
that's right okay they won't remember
the games that everybody was playing
everybody was playing everybody right
left and middle history is segmented
it's really interesting
when people talk about the spanish flu
for instance
often they don't talk about world war
one
they just have to read about it you're
like oh wow that kind of habits
simultaneously for the most part
there are a lot of times in history
where people will reference something
like
the great depression and then you gotta
understand the context around world war
one before it and
what what led up to these things but you
know we do a couple we do we do these
things with history
the story was the pandemic you're right
in 100 years they'll be like the
pandemic
there will be a separate historical
moment where they'll read about the
election but they won't be in the same
context
yes how we got jimmied we got gamed
again i don't want to sound like a
denialist because
i've never seen in my lifetime the
hospitals
overflow so that's true
do not even tweet me anything about that
that's true
but who did it hit
one more time the institutionalized
elderly
the very thing the government's
responsible for so when i see fauci
doing his morning talk shows
what is the nursing home strategy sir
because we now know before kovid 400
000 people died in the nursing home a
year
from communicable diseases wow and 550
000 died from covid we got a covert
every year in these places
now biden wants to come with 400
billion to deal with it okay
that's good but before we crap that
money down a hole you want to tell me
specifically what we're doing
or are the orange juice contractors
going to eat it up
so she is you're you're you're talking
about
what they did with putting coveted
patients in nursing homes yeah they took
they took the positive and put them in
with the with the
healthy to clear out the hospital
so you uh i guess you're suing i'm suing
the state of michigan for this
we've come up with an asterisk we have a
death count
and then there'll be an asterisk vital
record search
so we add those in okay
when did they die they won't tell us
how old were they they won't tell us
what was their race they won't tell us
and specifically
where was the primary residence was it a
nursing home
are you pulling a cuomo here
are we trying to hide statistical
deaths to make it look better because
look
as you add more deceased people to a
list
and less of the deceased people come
from a nursing home
you look like a winner why won't you
give it to me
this is our data why do i have to sue my
this is not the soviet union i think
the reason is probably obvious isn't it
because the number is probably bad like
with what cuomo did
even as ripe today as we stand we're no
better than
average which is what we like to say in
michigan
we didn't know better no worse
until the data comes out teacher
rednecked account
and he'll start counting what happens if
it comes out and the data comes out it
shows that it's a lot worse
that's bad now here's the thing what
happens if they give me the data and it
shows what they're reporting to be true
guess what i'm going to do
i'm going to write that that's the
honest
and dignified and professional
thing to do i just don't think we have
journalism anymore
you know i guess we we don't have real
reporters anymore
we do should we just name a few but
there's a small handle okay we'll name
them
do that let's do that before we dog the
whole institution
it's not true i'll give you one you give
me one ready all right
paul legan i can give you matt taibi
i can give you the national ones
christine mcdonald i'm yeah i'm going to
give you
so who are they tell me who these people
are i'm doing it they're um
they're people in michigan that do good
work you know i'll give you that i'll
i'll correct myself there are a lot of
good local reporters out there doing
really good work
yes i end up following a lot of these
guys uh men and women
when there's there's breaking news and
it comes from a certain area or a
certain city
i know that for the most part if you go
to a local reporter
it's usually pretty good these people
aren't the ones chasing the national
story and grifting to try and make the
national people chase them
exactly and they should be paid more
right and they should be respected and i
don't want to dog
them because i i know in minneapolis
they're for real
in chicago and la i i know
pancho ortiz in mcallen texas that guy
does both sides of the board
oh no there's a lot of us so we're not
dogging
reporters we're dogging the business
i'll tell you this
i think you're right i think i should
correct my statement again the problem
is
the powerful moneyed interests that fund
all this stuff
are not the local journalists who are
actually reporting on what's going on
give me it again brother that's right
right it is these powerful national uh
wealthy interests that are funding
who runs the newspapers now hedge funds
yeah
they're tearing them up you're wrong the
local newspapers are collapsing
they can't compete with the national
newspapers are over but
i love newspapers you know why they're
the best
kindling for a natural fire there's
nothing better than the news
one it's like a fireplace yeah it is
it's
i don't know what else you use to start
it yeah you actually you ball it up make
it it helps get things going
i mean i mean newsrooms in general right
you used to have men
it's crazy when i drive to some of these
small towns you see a big old it's like
the so-and-so gazette or whatever and
i'm like they used to have a newspaper
here
not anymore they don't have a web uh
newspaper
because they can't compete the national
level yeah the the ads have become
you know google and facebook contributed
to this but it's also that the new york
times can serve local ads
so the big players dominate the market
if you live
in the middle of nebraska and you go you
go to these big prominent news websites
you're gonna get ads for the middle of
nebraska you're gonna get ads for
your local grocery store so you don't
need the local paper selling ads anymore
and then if people are like if i'm gonna
pay for news i'm gonna pay for the new
york times why would i pay for a local
paper
100 so what i do with my podcast
is i try in the week to do
one big solid story so when i do it
that's hours and only hours and we beat
everybody and you gotta chase us
for instance saturday is the seven year
anniversary of flint
i bet you nothing was gonna happen in
the great state of michigan until i just
said that
did they they they finally fixed the
fights right i got you
hello everybody at home i got you hello
new york times
i got you remember flint
they finally fixed the pipes right yeah
no yeah
man still bad nah man it's like
you know you know what i got in flint
orange drink
they they got that news click no they
didn't
so it's still bad ain't nobody drinking
the water in flint yeah
what did it do to us flint
what else i was thinking like
i think it's always been bad for humans
you know it's always been like we're
struggling to survive we're lucky to be
alive
and now it's just less bad
but like there's still lead in the water
like there's not feast we
we have clean drinking water which is
kind of a first in humanity i guess the
romans maybe
started to so
it's not like it's falling apart it's
never really been that great
you know well but look come on you'd be
better off in the middle of the woods
finding
a dirty puddle and drinking it than you
would the water in flint they had
chemical plant runoff and they had
lead eroding in the pipes it's not that
bad now i mean but
i i would like to actually go back and
have a
muddy water and some and some land
that's mine
and some you know like one of these
bbc movies about the vikings where i'm
running around you know and
shooting elk and stuff yeah i wouldn't
mind that but you don't live very long
i thought we were supposed to be
improving i smell rot
that's what you've been talking i think
i think no matter how much technology
improves there's always the struggle of
maintaining things
like we still have people who live in
the middle of the wilderness
we still have people with their i mean
they're undiscovered tribes we could
develop all the best technology in the
world and i still think there will be
poor people who are living in
in squalor yeah the world's getting
crowded isn't it
yeah or is a great philosopher once
wrote
what goes up must come
down spinning wheels
going around do you think who was that i
don't know
dj thomas or something we could evolve
to a place where humans are
all like consciously aware awesome
connected unified or are we always going
to have a segment
of people that are like dumb like kind
of dumb animals that need to be herded
i kind of like both
i like the dumb animal
and the superhuman because remember what
freud really said break it down
the civilized person and the animal
person
the you know the wider they get from
each other the more unhappy you are the
more anxiety
the animal gives up his pleasure for
longevity that's the civil person
that's really i thought he was brilliant
that's really what's going on
in our lives are we gonna be animals are
we gonna be civil or
i like being both you're gonna have a
good mix man
you gotta you gotta think long term you
gotta but people don't want us to be
that
no they want to be short-term they don't
want us to be they don't like the animal
part of us
right there they want to be relatively
nice you have to be nice and be nice at
work
raise your hand raise your hand don't
say wash your hands
and don't say the wrong words because
for so long tell it to the hand
the animals get angry they start banging
the bars and then they start ripping
things down
and blowing things up and that's what
the the government and the people in
power are afraid that there's going to
be some sort of chaotic i don't even
call it revolution but chaotic evolution
or de-evolution
so they're like no we have to create
strict rules we want these people to be
to follow us they want us we want them
to use our money that we
say and i think it's it's holding us
back from turning into like the homo
sapien
is going to evolve into some other type
of hominid or some a bunch of different
types of
robots bro and cybernetic hominids a
brain in a jar connected to a car
battery yes
yeah that's exactly what we're about to
become all the above that's one way to
put it psychics
there'll be wild animal humans there
will be humans on mars that are like
bigger there will be humans in
deep space that are really long we're
going to cybernetically
integrate ourselves with machines that's
been that's that's
what you're going to do no that's what
i'm going to be calling the goal is for
a lot of these
these wealthy industrialists elon musk
neural link yes
to integrate humans with machines well
why wouldn't we because look
already we tethered ourselves to one we
got we're
interfacing with these machines right
now yeah but this one
yeah these for sure but this one is part
of me
this phone is and if you make it so i
can stick it inside myself and never
lose it at the bar
i might do it what if they hack it well
and then start making you think crazy
things and all of a sudden you just go
nuts that's called marriage
oh yeah
yeah a lot of people are worried about
the neural links stuff because there's
so much we got we gotta discover but
my response to the knurling stuff when
people are like would you get it oh i
wouldn't get it i'm scared it's like
let the technology happen before you
start talking about whether you're
worried about it or not
this is exponential if i went if i went
to you
15 years ago and said would you want to
put a tracking device in your pocket
where the government can see where
you're going and big corporations and
know when you're pooping
you'd be like no way i'd never do that
now you're like i love this thing but i
go like what do i get for it
access to the summation of human
knowledge i would be like
that's interesting maybe in fact
we did so it's no use going back and
asking the
the question we all knew that right yes
yeah people are going to neural link
right up did you see terminator 2
you guys seen the movie i'll be back
again i thought it was uh like a
dystopian fantasy when i saw it
in the 90s and now i'm realizing
whoa dude that might actually happen
that's crazy that machines could
we give over to this thing and then it
takes control
do you see the new terminator where i
guess like the machine
nanoparticles infected the dude and he
became a cyborg person or something
so in like one of the later movies i
don't they made too many of these
like i guess what what's the name of the
kid john connor is that yeah
yeah he he apparently gets infected by
nanotech which
integrates him with skynet or whatever
and he was like
i guess the story was something i could
be getting it wrong so correct me in the
comments if i'm wrong
he said something like skynet realized
they couldn't win so they decided to
integrate with humans and they're like
quick kill him i'm like wait wait wait
what's wrong with that like he's he's
super powerful
he's like basically indestructible he's
still him he's doing his thing
wouldn't you want nanobots to be like
you know it's like tony stark in the in
the in the
in avengers where he presses the butt on
his chest and he gets a suit of armor
wouldn't you want to be suit like have
superpowers thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time